what else has been going on well a
couple of days ago Christie's you may
have heard of this auctioned off 40
years of Star Trek memorabilia from all
these Star Trek television shows and
movies they auctioned off props costumes
models of the enterprise well guess what
Christie's is right across the street
from our show right here at Rockefeller
Center right across the street and we
happen to have a mr. Spock character at
our show he's been with our show for a
long time there he is
we use him in a lot of sketches he's
been we've you've been using him
constantly for years anyway it's always
been our Spock's dream to own a piece of
the real Star Trek so here's what we did
since Christie's is right across the
street we gave our Spock $1,500 of the
show's money and sent him over to
Christie's to see what he could get we
sent a camera crew here's what happened
captain's log stardate last Thursday
morning have sent mr. Spock across the
street to Christie's auction house his
mission to spend $1,500 of the show's
money to fulfill his lifelong dream
[Music]
dominate the enterprise dining room set
there a dining room set seemed the
perfect choice pre-auction estimates
place the item at $1,000 well within box
budget fifty eight hundred and fifty
with Spock thank you at nine fifty one
thousand eleven hundred thank you 1,200
1,300 1,400 1,500 1,600 1,600 bit here
1,700 in it the bidding way too high
sold
not one twenty one the Vulcan chairs now
there's six barstools in the lot Volken
chairs perfect Spock boldly tried again
out bids with me 450 500 1,100 1,200
1,300 1,400 now new bidder there 1,500
1,600 the Vulcan chairs at 1,600 no now
these are so you 1600 now it's against
you are we sure but again he was
thwarted sold low 107 this is the
Starship Enterprise a model so let's
start the absentee bidder I have 600 bit
600 here 2500 completely takes me out in
the front row here at 2500 anywhere else
2800 when he failed a third time the
crafty Vulcan used his communicator to
summon help 6000 here at 6000 the bids
here with me 6,500 online I took $9,000
in cash from the paid scholarship fund
and gave it to my old
8500 online now at 9500 10000 sir thank
you 75,000 80,000 85,000 I have 90,000 I
have a hundred thousand heroes but even
my vast resources were no match for the
deep pockets of rich online nerds sold
the online spock transported himself out
of the option house he still had my cash
though and he still had his dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is half human filling there and coming
up Jim Gaffigan see with a burger